if you had to choose between opening up
a store where you worked at the
scheduled time or going to a client's
house to secure a $115,000 deal for your
boss which would you choose when he was
23 Mark Cuban faced that very decision
he chose the deal over the store while
the choice seemed right to him it got
him fired more about that later to
understand The Man Behind such bold
decisions we have to go back to when
Mark cubin was just 12 years old and
sold garbage bags door to door in a
suburb of Pittsburgh he later sold
powdered milk which wasn't of a step up
he recalled in his book how to win at
the sport of business in every job I
would justify it in my mind whether I
loved it or hated it that I was getting
paid to learn and every experience would
be of value when I figured out what I
wanted to do when I grew up he figured
out very quickly that he wanted to run
his own business and boy has he been
successful from co-founding
broadcast.com a Pioneer in online
broadcasting to owning the Dallas
Mavericks to his iconic role on Shark
Tank if I offered you $30 million for
the company would you take it Mark cubin
is worth 5.2 billion yet even he
grappled with self-doubt when he started
out admitting in reality I had as much
doubt as confidence I was just hoping
the confidence would win over the doubt
and it would all work out for the best
after graduating from Indiana University
in the early 80s he looked for a job
where he could learn more about
computers the personal Computing
industry was starting to take off he
took a job at melon Bank in his hometown
of Pittsburgh where he took old manual
systems at small Banks and converted
them to automated systems he didn't last
long there all of 9 months his next stin
trying to franchise the TV repair
business lasted 8 months then at the age
of 23 he took off to Dallas Texas where
in his words he pursued fun son money
and women he crashed at a friend's
apartment sleeping on the couch or the
floor lived off bar food and bartended
at night while hunting for a job in the
computer industry by day he managed to
convince a store to hire him to sell
software to despite his lack of
experience when interviewers asked what
do you do if a customer has a question
about a software package and you don't
know the answer he responded I would
look it up in the manual and find the
answer for them not only was that a good
answer but that's actually what he did
he'd spend every night reading computer
manuals to learn everything he could
about the products he was selling he
felt this would give him an edge over
others and he believes his passion for
learning is one of the main reasons he's
so successful clearly it worked because
customers were so impressed with his
knowledge that they hired him to install
software at their offices he charged $25
an hour for Consulting split between him
and the store and the extra cash allowed
him to move into an apartment with his
own bedroom cubin realized he loved
working with technology but he hated
having a boss 9 months into his new job
a client asked him to come into the
office to close a $15,000 deal the
problem was the client wanted him to
come at the same time he was expected to
open up the software store at 9:00 a.m.
he chose to close the sale rather than
open up shop cubin recalled we all have
to make that make or break call to
follow orders or do what you know is
right I followed my first instinct close
the sale he got a coworker to open up
the shop instead however his boss wasn't
impressed and fired him while most
people would have been crushed by the
firing Cuban had a different perspective
he thought it never really matters how
many times you fail you only have to be
right once getting fired was a blessing
in disguise it ignited his drive to
start his own company he created micro
Solutions Inc which sold personal
computers and software and helped
companies and individuals install them
he called up all the clients he had
worked with at the shop informing them
he was now on his own and saw their
business they were hesitant to hire him
since he didn't have employees or even a
company phone so Cuban's initial
approach focused on building trust when
he tried to convince one company to buy
an accounting software he was selling he
said he'd install it for for free and
offered to refund 100% of their money if
the software didn't work for them they
just need to pay the $500 it took for
Cuban to buy the software from the
publisher and in exchange he could use
them as a reference Cuban wasn't going
to make any money on the sale he was
investing in building a client base and
reputation which put him in a better
position to negotiate future deals he
got along so well with another client
that its CEO Martin Woodall ended up
becoming a partner in his business micro
solutions they were the perfect match
wood all was detail oriented and anal as
Cuban described him whereas Cuban was
disorganized and not a details person
Cuban understood that success in
business isn't just about individual
talent but also about surrounding
herself with the right people who fill
in the gaps in your own abilities or in
his words don't lie to yourself each of
us has to face the reality of who we are
and what we are they even weathered a
major Financial scam when their
secretary stole nearly all of the
company's money Cuban says she Whited
out the names of the checks he wrote to
vendors and altered them to her own name
sending $83,000 of the company's $85,000
to herself while most people would have
freaked out with a capital f he didn't
because he thought it a waste of energy
and the hard lesson he learned was that
no one was going to cover my obligations
but me he returned to work put his head
down and searched for new ideas reading
every book related to computers that he
could get his Hands On Learning about
the features that worked well and the
bugs in the software he still reads for
3 hours every day after 7 years he sold
micro Solutions in 1990 to CompuServe a
subsidiary of H&R Block for 6 million he
took the money and started trading tech
stocks at a time when they were Sor it
was during this time that he identified
a gap in the digital world that would
change his life while hanging out with
his college buddy Todd Wagner they
winded up at the fact that they couldn't
listen to the basketball games from
Indiana University while living in Texas
so they decided to launch the audio
streaming service audionet with just
$8,000 initially audionet focused on
broadcasting college sports then it went
from audio to video and this was a
decade before YouTube audionet
eventually became broadcast.com they
recognized the potential of the platform
Beyond Sports to broadcast anything over
the Internet including shareholder
meetings and earnings calls the idea was
to reach people during the day when they
were in the office Yahoo ended up
purchasing broadcast.com in 1999 for
whopping 5.7 billion in stock however
Yahoo would end up regretting the sale
it shut down much of its broadcast
services and broadcast.com was
eventually discontinued in hindsight
it's been called one of the worst
internet Acquisitions of all time for
Mark cubin it catapulted him into the
billionaires Club the first thing he did
was buy a plane the asset he values most
is time and is Gulf Stream 5 Business
Jet brought him more of it he didn't
even see it in person when he bought it
online for $40 million setting a
Guinness world record for the largest
online purchase at the time the golf
stream was just the beginning the iconic
purchase he's most known for was in 2000
when the dieh hard basketball fan bought
the Dallas Mavericks for 285 million
what the is that team worth now 2.5
billion godam Cuban brought a Fresh
Approach to NBA team ownership he
ditched the Box seats billionaire owners
were accustomed to and sat behind the
bench notoriously yelling at the rafts
this Hands-On approach also changed the
team's atmosphere and the Mavericks won
their first NBA Championship in 2011 for
Cuban business is more intense than any
sport with sports you know how long the
game will last usually in business
competition is 24 hours a day 7 days a
week 365 days a year he once quipped if
your girlfriend asks you which is more
important them or your business you give
the right answer he's so fired up about
competition that after becoming Filthy
Rich he didn't rest on his Laurels Cuban
launched the highdef television network
hdnet he co-founded the entertainment
company 2929 entertainment and in 2022
he launched a drug company that promises
steep discounts on hundreds of
prescription drugs to tackle the high
price of drugs in the US these days
instead of working 24 hours a day 7 days
a week 365 days a year he's cut back to
a mere 18 hours a day to spend precious
time with his family he met his wife
Tiffany at a gym in Dallas in 1997 they
have three children and live in a chatau
style home larger than five basketball
courts when he was young he drive by big
houses like his every weekend and wonder
if who lived there what do they do for a
living how do they manage to afford a
place like that the next time you pass
by is sprawling EST State like Mark hbin
used to remember that countless hours
failures Blood Sweat and Tears years
likely pav the way to that doorstep
self-education was pivotal in Cuban's
Journey proving that with the right
resources anyone can Master complex
subjects and there's a free and easy way
to learn brilliant is a website and app
where you can learn math computer
science and data science interactively
instead of learning in a stale classroom
environment you can learn intuitively by
working your way through their puzzles I
like to spend 10 minutes a day solving
Brilliance logic puzzles to improve my
analytical thinking you can start at
your own Comfort level and then progress
to more advanced lessons and if you get
stuck you can view the explanation to
discover the correct approach you can
try out brilliant for free for 30 days
using my link in the description
brilliant.org newthink if you're one of
the first 20000 people to sign up with
my link you'll get 20% off your premium
subscription unlocking all of Brilliance
courses thanks for watching for news
think I'm Cindy pal